hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay um
I'm somewhere I don't remember where I
read on the comments that there was an
important message in the one room um
that I was in before I try to make my
way back there ha ha ha ok safe zone for
now this bathroom still oh that wasn't
open before oh I see some no yes I don't
know aw crap okay okay
ah oh it really is a sound that makes
the game oh I can't get in there oh I
need to go through the outside to get
back there okay uh uh okay I can get
back outside by going either yeah I have
to go back down to get back out okay hoo
boy all right here we go
oh my battery's gonna run out uh-huh
uh-huh okay um I was in there
I don't think I killed the zombies down
here I did I did I did I did I'm okay
it's through here it's through the
hospital ah oh oh oh oh battery someone
suggested that I do selective cheating
just so I can get batteries but now this
this is what's gonna make the game
terrifying I can tell just uh uh where
is it where is it where is it where the
freaky frack is it who's here Oh out of
your head your head your head is wrong
your head is wrong I gotta go down a
level
oh my goodness still there buddy okay
please keep keep calm okay I got to ah
okay yeah this is gonna work gosh ah ha
ha ha ha oh I learned a secret technique
I stand on their head they can't kill me
ah ha some of them are tougher than
others
ok uh uh uh look it was through here ah
ah uh uh uh uh ah damn it [ __ ] up there
we go ah ah ah hit me what the hell uh
okay all right okay up Oh
I go through with this one breaks oh ah
nah doc okay up
okay they go back up and someone said
something about the map up here pointing
to the X oh this is a map of the roof
there's an X there why is there an X
there and there's an X on the top of the
building to the side of the building I
don't know
Oh items oh okay
oh I got bullet ammo now okay anyway um
I need to get back to that room I get
there through here no no wait what ah
through here each color I broke the
other one I broke one of these come on
each color button
for each door what huh
okay each color button or each door is
that for or or for each story each color
button for each door okay
um got me
um I'm confessed look at that
what does that mean
each color button for each door there's
only one button I saw and everything
else is pitch black not like to sees
they're an item behind here hi yes there
is
is there an item down here I can't see
anything it's all black on black I think
there was a battery here that I picked
up earlier Oh baloney
okay anyway
Oh balls
okay all right let me see we start
backtracking a bit hmm try one of these
rooms where the monster afterwards
popped out at me maybe No
huh okay good I can recharge my
batteries up to five which is something
nice ooh this is still locked this goes
nowhere
besides the dark the power room I don't
need to go the power room no okay
nothing there oh okay I'm actually gonna
I'm actually gonna pause it for a moment
here because I don't want to just spend
the whole episode being lost so I'm
gonna figure out what I need to do and
then I'm gonna come back so I'll see you
in a bit
hello everybody all right I thought
about what I needed to do what was going
on is I didn't turn around see there's
another thing here that I can jump out
on yeah okay that's what I need to do it
did have to do with that I just was too
stupid to realize it at the time
Oh making progress oh these are padded
rooms padded cells oh my oh darkness
darkness darkness battery huh oh come on
please please battery please please
please oh it's so dark oh you gotta be
kidding me
oh thank you okay oh where the [ __ ] am I
where am i red room bedroom bedroom
bedroom huh oh
ah exit or was there an exit oh that was
the ex door was the door for the exes oh
my goodness uh-huh okay come on come on
come on there we go
Oh till dark oh come on yeah okay this
is the basement level so ah can't see
anything oh why so dark
why pitch blackness can I just have a
little a little bit of a light little
little light please please um was all
the way at the top
uh-huh ah oh yeah you stay all the way
over there ha ha
Rilla Rilla Rilla ah ah hello
oh good turn it to a battery better uh
uh-oh
okay am I supposed to go up here or some
oh through here okay
ah ow
okay down again not it down okay up that
was dumb
that was a mistake okay what surprise
let's just cut this
No yeah okay there we go climb up
through oh not today not night Oh balls
out come on let me they're heavy they're
everything let me through ah ah another
button this is the same place
this is the same place why I'm in this
hit please uh-huh
why did I come out there
ah girl a going get all the way all the
way all the way all the way all the way
all the way [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah no not again huh huh huh
oh I get it the colors
ah but where the [ __ ] you [ __ ] is at
remember blue light to blue door I don't
know I don't know oh I'm out wait a
second
well my plus I recharges I have no
bullets left
ah - that's not enough I got one hit
left mmm doesn't open
Oh Thank You batteries have you pills ah
get it ma'am ma'am take that there we go
oh okay
Oh strange the logs missing where is
this this is back here I don't know
where that door was blue door I don't
know I don't know no no I don't know I
don't know no no come here come here
[ __ ] oh come here
get some yeah yeah yeah there we go
there we go okay save mid combat that is
it okay there we go
you dead okay okay okay
he's dead why was he in here
oh god I'm in the wrong place aren't I I
have no idea where to go I came in
through here this is where the Blue Room
was and I can't go back I've got to come
up through here up doesn't does it
no no no nope nope nope Redrum Redrum
okay so whoo okay
I remember seeing a green room anywhere
no I do not I don't remember seeing a
green room anywhere so what does that
mean I don't know I gotta go back go
back
Jeff up up up up maybe over here
somewhere
uh-huh do a room down there green green
green no green no green
hey hey okay I see a green line is that
something is that a hint that green is
up here that a handy hint no maybe this
is the green level like it's somewhere
on this floor that would make sense
wouldn't it in here ah aha what did that
do it even give a cutscene
okay all right that's a mystery that's
gonna have to wait until next time cuz
I'm all out of time for now thank you
everybody for watching hope you enjoyed
it I'll see you in the next part bye-bye